and action
I've dreamt of acting on parts film
there's something huge happening every
day so it hasn't energy and a force
behind it but I've never really
experienced before I was armed the park
movies really big and huge I really
wanted that challenge as an actress if
you've never seen a pirates relief this
is really an exciting one start with
it's so fresh so different so creepy and
yet very funny for this moment on we
ought to be allies considering weigh on
at times they were more than ice and now
we have a bunch of new characters and
returner is a young man trying to free
his father will turn I will break my
father's chest Tracy Smith is an
intelligent young woman and she's kind
of an outcast I'm not looking for
trouble what's horrible is lead we were
so lucky when we got Javier Bardem to
play company on all of our cows ours
were the great villains of all time
he's full of rage the knee of vengeance
Spirent and then we have iconic
characters that have meant so much to us
growing up with this franchise Jack
Byron will always be Jack Powell Johnny
Depp is back is Captain Jack really and
I kind of character where the best
characters ever created for cinema oh
thank you looks like seeing old friends
again johnny is a great guy investigator
he does it so well all the parts movies
are epic we wanted this movie to feel
just as graham what we bring to the
screen is great storytelling with
wonderful characters caught up in this
magical fantastic world
it's time
- hunter pirate it's like a ripe
[Music]
you
you